[Musique]
je suis reconnaissant envers ma femme
deborah et j'espère qu'un jour notre
famille sera aussi belle que la vôtre
qu'est ce que c'est tu me trouves
pourris gâtés
tu aimes qu'on s'occupe de toi y'a pas
de mal à ça j'aime y avait cet outil cas
qu une personne veut la mort d'une autre
qui suis-je pour juger
si tu exécutes mes ordres
tu as tout à y gagner
je fais du bon boulot en laisse en vie
un témoin d'un meurtre
je ne suis ni les femmes ni les enfants
je ne peux pas prendre ce risque
allez ouste et enfants en faire allez
vous en c'est mon jour de chance ou mon
dernier
tu as une seconde
tu veux qu'on soit partenaire tu
t'occupes des détails
moi je suis
on va manquer d'étagères tu descends des
gens derrière mon dos c'est pour petit
qui pensent que leur père est un type
bien
si nos chemins se croisent à nouveau des
gens taire toute ta famille papa
[Musique]
y a plus aucune raison d'avoir peur mais
j'ignorais que deux verbes
[Applaudissements]
tu cherches iceman
je devrais toucher des royalties pour ce
moment là
pas mal en pis et seigneur tu fais quoi
tu pries
tu penses que dieu va venir te sauver
des huit descentes pour moi
il doit être occupée
[Musique]